you need to be absolutely confident and
I think it's always better to be overly
confident than pessimistic because I
realize sometimes after games that you
know
I was actually way too confident here I
was way too optimistic but if you're not
optimistic if you're not looking for
your chances You're Gonna Miss
opportunities there are plenty of
players in history who have been you
know immensely talented but they're just
too pessimistic they see too many
dangers that are not there and so on so
that they cannot perform they're very
good players but they could be one of
one of the best if they just you know
had had more confidence so and when I'm
you know I'm analyzing with them when
I'm looking at chess I realize they know
everything about the game but
nevertheless they cannot play there's a
missing thing yeah yeah it's like a
Winner's Edge yeah you need to have that
edge you need to have that confidence
you need to have that you know absolute
belief that you're the best and you'll
win every time